the point is the people wants change
they imply though remain unchanged they
may not necessarily want you they took
you for fools did war I don't know if
they took us for fools
last month Venezuela's opposition
attempted their boldest move yet to try
to get the military to come over to
their side and unseat the government but
the effort failed my guest this week
here in London is Vanessa Nieman
representative to the Venezuelan
opposition leader and self declared
president juan y doe what happens next
[Music]
and that's an omen welcome to Canton
exam thank you thank you for having me
it's a pleasure to be here you have what
amounts to a failed uprising in
Venezuela behind you and yet your
movement continues to make incredibly
optimistic predictions about seating the
government why is that because the
situation is unsustainable we have
eighteen point seven million Venezuelans
who have lost 25 pounds over the last
year that's the beginning of a major
famine you've been saying it's
unsustainable for the last two years huh
you've been sending its own sustain
becomes increasingly unsustainable
everything you said you said the other
day that in two weeks time the lights
who are going out two weeks on the
lights are still there and president
Maduro is still in his palace isn't he
with his armed forces well with some of
his armed forces I mean the head of his
Intelligence Agency is now safely
ensconced in the yeah we've got plenty
more no not really I mean they are
negotiating behind his back there are
negotiations going on right now and they
are looking to - to get out and the
situation is just actually run out in
the last few days we had one Guido
insisting that he had the backing of 80
to 85 percent of the Venezuelan military
based on what based on the fact that
they are suffering as well they are
going home two wives who tell them that
their work is a humiliation to children
that are crying and hungry 80 to 85
percent of the military or the worker
bees of the military they are not
reaping the 8.8 billion dollars of drug
trafficking and gold trafficking does
nothing to save on your side nothing
absolutely on this you failed you failed
to bring the military on tarsem no on
the contrary the problem is that we have
Cuban intelligence officers preventing
them prevent following their children
and preventing preventing them from
rising up and we have over 200 military
being tortured there have been
at over 12 if all one way to overspend
excuse me before one way though took
office there were over 12 military
uprising attempts by the military
spontaneously your latest attempt though
was described by the crisis group as
poorly conceived and easily subdued
that's hardly a success is it the point
is the people wants change they my
though is real unchanged they don't
necessarily want you on me I'm not your
movement I'm an ambassador for the
movement look I think that they do they
want out from this drug cartel regime
that tortures people it is causing a
bigger Exodus than Syria this is not it
violates its own cosmology it's not a
big exodus than serious serious at least
12 million people why we take into
account those who've been what 12
million people it's about 5 million
people have that I'm talking about
internally displaced but we will have at
the end of the year an eight point four
million by the end of next year that for
addiction UNHCR and the OAS the UNHCR
isn't exactly you know a bastion of
right-wing nests now is it apparently
your biggest mistake last month was to
trust the word of the government
officials you were talking to
traffickers Human Rights news anyway so
why is it such a big surprise that you
were played by them why why because they
took you for fools didn't well I don't
know if they took us for fools I mean we
will hope that the that the positioning
of come in defense of the people come in
defense of the Constitution in accept
honesty and be part of the right side of
history would appeal to them
unfortunately I think that we rather
underestimated that the people behind
this and I was not personally involved
I'm an ambassador I am not the president
I am the chain of command flows down to
me not upwards the people who were
behind this and took the decisions I
you know did war perhaps a bit naive
about the amount of money being made by
the military and their drug trafficking
activities there's another psychological
component which you will know well from
game theory for instance is you you and
you're trying to negotiate a situation
you have all these different players and
what you know what you know but you
don't know what the other person knows
about what you know so basically we
don't you made a number of important
mistakes but the people who pay for
those mistakes are the people aren't
they no according to the UN in just
eight days from January the 21st to the
29th where the protests began right more
than a thousand people were arbitrarily
detained many of them were just kids
most of them were kept incommunicado for
days without access to family continue
to stall we have three hundred and
thirty thousand Venezuelan commit murder
you have murdered by
government-sponsored care lives at risk
three hundred thirty thousand have been
murdered by government-sponsored games
seven million students and the best you
can see a new things we see you fully
conceived and easy what are you what are
you recommending military are use are
you advocating a military intervention
I'm not here to answer your questions
you I'm asking you where's your red line
here when at what point do you stop
urging the people to come out because
you're putting more lives for all the
other options then what do you recommend
that attempt what happened on a pond
April 30th and May first is in keeping
with the Constitution that was drafted
by Hugo Chavez and I didn't work why
should people trust you now why should
people come out because now they know
because now they know how how the regime
is fractured that the austalia video and
Padrino Lopez and that Achilles army now
has an arrest warrant he is the husband
adman they also know that you raised
your best hand and lost know why is it
that that's what the Crisis Group says
you've lost remote so is that the only
view Colonel Crisis Group commentator
Carlos Romero described Venezuelan
politics now as shaken he said the
people were confused wounded and
unmotivated as a result of what we have
done rather than twenty years of
dictatorship and starvation and torture
I'm sorry no and we stand firm despite
the fact that since then 28% of the
National Assembly has been you know it
has been arrested and our Vice President
is now disappeared disappeared in the
classic Latin American sense of the term
as in taken with no proof of life given
and mr. Vidal insists in the last few
days for the rights of all people no
matter what I just asked the question
sure he has insisted in the last few
days that there is absolute unity in the
opposition that's pretty hard to believe
what do you mean of course he was
reported on May the 5th that some of the
opposition's senior leaders have begun
playing the blame game over what went
wrong so it's unlikely that unity unity
is when there when the persecution is
absolutely across all political parties
the National Assembly's members that
have been that have been now exiled
since May first or have been disappeared
or across all political party what
they're my opposition in Venezuela has
then the president divided for years
no no I'm sorry sir I'm sorry to him
what has happened is this after many
years of the international community
blaming us saying oh you can't get your
act together and you need to unify we
have unified we have a president
according to our Constitution called one
way though every single party is behind
him my appointment for instance was
approved by every single political party
in the National Assembly with unanimity
hang on ironically what has happened is
now that we are unified the
international community has fractured
now you have the Montevideo initiative
National Contract group the Lima group
conversations in Havana and
conversations are now and all over the
place and the irony is that that's the
ultimate hypocrisy is that the
international community like a bunch of
squabbling children at the time when we
have our activist since when that has
new trails my people since when have you
discovered this newfound unity because
by November last year the fight the
fights just so bad by November last year
the fights were so bad that Luis
Salamanca political scientists former
director of the National Electoral
Council destroyed January text riod
January 10th 2019 as well when I
suddenly came together really yes of
course under one way though when he
became the de facto president of
Venezuela because mother would or is in
violation of our Constitution we unified
behind our Constitution not everybody
seemed very happy at the way he took the
presidency what do you mean
yes I'm Henry Ellis with Henry KCAP
realist one of the most visible
opposition figures said in February when
wider took possession of the assembly
the view of the majority of the
Venezuelan opposition was that he ought
not to be appointed president the 23rd
of January the 23rd of January came and
he appointed himself we didn't have any
information it surprised many leaders in
the opposition sciences Venezuelan
politics for a long time for good reason
he's a two-time loser presidential
candidate and he does not have the
support of the Venezuelan people one way
though also his views are automatically
to be dismissed because they don't
coincide me no they don't coincide with
the will of the Venezuelan people who
want out from this regime he is not the
leader of a political party he is not
even really involved in the political
party anymore and he fled the country
and came in under dubious circumstances
I mean if that's the purpose that's the
one person you choose when you have
millions of people weeping in the
streets for guai law and and
he
in the country and you can see him when
he went on the tour you know the
Diaspora in order to users and Dora is
still in the presidential palace and new
people are trying to find protection
he's in the presidential palace because
the Russian military the international
left thinks that it's perfectly fine
okay for the Russians to invade us
basically and just talk about the
millage and have military advisors and
Cuban intelligence about the military
and Hezbollah and Al and the eland of
foreign terrorist organization which
personally intimidated hang on and we
just quino's know I stopped the uprising
most of the houses you same way the
Nazis my mom we don't need speeches I
want to talk about the military talk
about the fact that it was reported that
bronc rider said he would probably
accept a US military intervention if the
United States proposed it you have been
talking to the US military your movement
has been talking to the US my
counterpart amassing - let me correct
you there factually my counterpart in
Washington DC
Carlos Vecchio will speak to them on
Monday that conversation has not
happened yet so you're pretty serious
about this military intervention but I'm
not serious we'll have a
commander-in-chief that's what our
president that is his decision to make
he says he's already been talking about
strategic and operational planning with
the head of the u.s. Southern Command
he ordered Carlos spec you to have that
conversation and that conversation has
been scheduled and announced on Twitter
by catalyst vacuum my counterpart in
Washington DC for Monday such a move
would also split the international
community again you say it's a split
anyway so you're not bothered about that
European Union says it doesn't want
military intervention the lima group
says it doesn't want military
intervention you don't care what they
think about this oh we are looking at
all the options we're also involved in
conversations and our negotiations to
find a Pacific's a peaceful solution a
peaceful resolution the offer is now and
has always been on the table for them to
leave the country peacefully on a plane
get out take their ill-gotten gains take
their ill-gotten
500 to 800
million dollars that they have stolen
okay take some portion of that and leave
and let us to get back to democracy and
let the eighty-five to ninety percent of
people in Venezuela who wants Maduro out
to carry on with their lives
many many about this you say they can
get on a plane get out of the country so
no justice and no accountability there
are these people who have been murdering
and torturing they just got off
scot-free how forgiving do you think the
Venezuelan people are - of me after what
you say has been done to the murdering
the torturing well that is something you
can download the document where you can
download the document it's called plan
police and it's in there we have a plan
for transitional justice it's in our
governance plan for transitional justice
in the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission which happens after you have
regime change and you know this because
we've done this this has happened a
number of times before so we will follow
the international standard on that
really the fact is these offers of
amnesty may well be illegal under
international law might well run counter
to Venezuela as international
obligations in January Human Rights
Watch called on you to amend your
amnesty bill saying that any amnesty
guaranteeing impunity by absorbing
government and military officials of the
most serious human rights violations
that's correct
incompatible with Venezuela that's
correct we can obligation that's correct
our ambassador to Czechoslovakia is
actually the one who brought the case to
the ICC she's a major human rights
lawyer tomorrow so cool so you don't
know these depends on what they have the
power the intern and we will take
direction from the International
Criminal Court on how on crimes against
humanity crimes people who commits
crimes against humanity is very
different case and go into a different
basket than people who are guilty of
money laundering drug trafficking about
people who murder who torture who are
enforced disappearances you're supplying
maggoty you're saying let the whole lot
get out no we are saying we
didn't distinguish when you are again
your facts are wrong really yes your
facts are also here our president
distinguished president has
distinguished that he has clearly stated
anybody has stated it at least twenty
times Tim that anybody who is not guilty
of crimes against humanity can be
offered amnesty those who are guilty of
crimes against humanity
do not get amnesty period and that's in
keeping with international law so I'm
not sure where you're getting your facts
it's about the third or fourth time in
this interview you're Ross so so why if
I'm so wrong why have all the human
rights organizations got onto your case
and said that this is something you
shouldn't be doing it for what's in
their minds I can only speak to the
failure of a didn't hear these ideas
either I don't know but I think you can
go on you can go online and find them
one this week
what what's extraordinary also is that
not only are you offering amnesty to
some of the military and government
personnel but you apparently offered to
give them a place in a transitional
government let's think about that from
them just asked a lot how forgiving do
you think Venezuelans will be that is
something that will be not saltation
with the Venezuelan people in what form
and what form will be it will be put to
them it will be put to them and
transitional government is not a
permanent government and you know how
transitions to democracy are always
complicated hard choices always have to
be made but again we look at the 330
thousand people the government has
murdered with armed gangs we look at the
18 point 7 million people on their way
to a major famine seven million of whom
are in danger imminent danger of dying
and or an imminent danger and image of
justice to magnify a so justice area is
being
so this regime who is shooting people
for college I'm not disputing
are you telling me then that justice
transition comes no transition comes
first those who come to realize the
error of their ways and come to love our
people in their country and their
constitution will have that credited to
them even if government even if they be
in the military even if they have these
crimes well that is something yes that
if long as we get the regime transferred
back of the country transition the
battery what do you mean I am absolutely
certain we need this dictatorship drug
cartel gone so that my country may be
itself again at any price they're not
they're not a government they do not
know that they were not they have the
gun they have the guns and we need the
guns for territorial control as well we
are also invaded by foreign terrorist
organizations there are also bombing our
allies and our neighbors there have been
two terrorist attacks by then you might
well calling the US military and you
might well call in the US military to do
the work for well there are there many
militaries who would be at the the
Colombian military has asked for
permission to come in and kill the ELN
terrorists on that are taking that their
trust Donald s is without Donald wait
wait a minute wait a minute you're
mixing I'm tagging you don't mixing I
was talking about the asking the US
military to come in if the US military
first of all you have not worked with
the military the US military's not
Donald Trump second of all and if these
are a lot of commander-in-chief military
yeah he's the commander commander in
chief but the methodology that does not
that's irrelevant I really yes of course
I am NOT here to comment on Venice or
under US politics and here to comment on
my country he won't comment on the
commander in chief of the military that
you may ask I am NOT a surgeon I have
not been at your movement on it no that
is not my that I'm not commenting on it
I am NOT a representative of the US
government I am a represent the
of the guado government period I'm here
to discuss my country and the blood on
the hands of the medulla dictatorship
which is actually the world's biggest
drug cartel importing drugs you said
that already
you said that already we now know that
high-level talks have taken place in
Norway
yes errantly not direct talks correct
mediated by Norway what's happened in
these talks
not much is the answer is the short
answer to that so what has been totally
unproductive yeah they were totally
unproductive there were an initial
outreach so because the lima group the
International contact group and in the
u.s. you love to comment on we're all
aware we're aware that no you know and
the UN also again not a bastion of
right-wing nests you know where were
aware of these talks and we sent two
representatives from the choir or
government the module ascent
side sent two representatives they did
not fly together they did not speak to
each other they did not have breakfast
together okay so my and the point was
each side was with the Norwegian
officials to state their position and
under what conditions they would
negotiate we stated what's the next step
so we stay we were very clear and my
president has been very clear and you
stated it once again online yesterday
what's the next step that we will enter
into any we will enter into good-faith
negotiations that entail an end of the
three-step plan we have laid forward
since January you're setting of the sea
for these two of course to send a set of
conditions of course there are
conditions to talks or conditions to any
job you buy a house there are conditions
it's a little different well of course
that's right there are 30 million lives
at stake so oh yes if there are
conditions for your purchase of ours no
you guys so you'll get a lay thousand
thirteen million you're gonna lay down
preconditions which the other side is
going to refuse know how helpful is now
we have now we the other side is the one
that never met its conditions the Maduro
regime is the one who has said it does
not want elections we are not blocking
free and fair elections the Maduro
regime has and the Madhu
regime is the one that has extended
talks in the past what has happened is
one thing we have had dialogues and we
had the dialogues
according to they chose the place they
chose the timing
they chose the representatives they kept
our political leaders in prison and we
said free the political prisoners no
free and they just carried on and in the
meantime they have stolen more money is
tortured more P is it a precondition of
these talks that Maduro steppers all
right absolutely and what makes you
think that they're going to do that for
you do you think because they were
negotiating to get him out already
there has been wait on the Thomas 8:20
saying you they were playing you know
they weren't they are he'll convince we
were serious yes absolutely I know for a
fact they were huh I thought I cannot
disclose on there but but I know for a
fact that they have been negotiating
actively with us and also with other
countries to find a way to take them
there are countries that have said that
they will take them so these talks are
quite advanced you think you can be a
winner that takes all in this really
take what all in the negotiations that
may actually know what it takes when you
have 30 million people living under a
dictatorship you think that there are
several other editions each conditions
no key conditions or the end of the
usurpation our transitional government
which is to be negotiated and free and
fair elections with proper international
observation I don't see how that's a
winner-take-all at all my country is
dying under there under the gaze of a
fractured and conflicted international
community that has just watched my
people die and be tortured and done
nothing about your international
community is given worldwide of
recognition he said I got it from inside
the country you know he absolutely does
have it from inside the country had
people on the streets that's not the
same thing is it what it what do you
expect then people on the streets is
power people on the sides is love people
on the streets is support P
on the streets is an expression and it
can come and brighter future and it can
come and go well it certainly went for
my daughter
didn't it who that's right because he he
won't get out of the way and he had a
you know he's there under a fraud he is
there as a torturer he is there as
someone who did not win is still there
our duty no we are not on the outside we
are in the hearts of the Venezuelan
people we are in with the legitimacy of
the of all the Western democracies or
the Demark all the countries there are
liberal democracies that have rule of
law recognize our Constitution and they
recognize the legitimacy of one way
though that we are in a situation where
a drug cartel has taken all the levers
of power by the way I mean you're gonna
succeed doesn't mean you're gonna die
trying
we have no option but to fight for our
people I will fight for my people until
I draw my last breath Vanessa no thanks
very much thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]